you take there's some things that he  says that I agree with and there's a lot  of out-of-pocket things he says that I  don't what do you agree with yes the men  should be the providers I don't mind  that at all of course every lady likes  to be taken care of he is the protector  he's the provider you know things like  little things like that Karachi the  first woman today that's told me that  she wants a protector and a provider  tell me why you like this I mean  I'm not you know big enough to fight  somebody out in the dangerous streets  like I've lived here my whole life and  there's a lot of creepos that come out  and harass you and say things to you  that just are not kind so you know  having somebody there to protect you and  know that you know if something does  happen everything will be okay